نايت
مثيره
وهناك عمليه سباق ثقيله الوزن
لنراقبها اتمنى ان تكون الموسيقى خضراء خذ
لكم جميعا اذا اننا نقوم بمزاج من الاثنين
او يدوا ان ارحب بشركات الاخبار الزائفه
هناك اناس كثر من هذه الشبكات هنا فهذه
مجموعه كبيره فانهم يتوقعون امرا كبير
لكنهم سوف يمنون بخساره كبيره الارقام
جيده حتى اللحظه وحتى هذه المرحله
ومن خلال عمليات التصديقات والتعيينات فا
لدينا اجمالي
تفويض لهذه التعيينات فقط لهذه الامثل
امسيه ومن هذه 30
وفزنا ب 200 واربعه
في
المركز الخامس
اي بمعنى
ان الارقام جيده وهناك
عمليه تعيين واذا اعتبارا من هذه اللحظه
فا لدينا
80 عمليه ربح وثلاث خسائر اليس هذا صحيحا
اذا ما كان هذا الامر في الانتخابات
العامه بدلا من هذه التعيين في نذكر
فهناك تفوق
بنسبه 51 بالمقابل ب 77 وفي ميزوري
55 الى
33 40
هو هو ضد ما يعرف بانها جربوش
هلاكم ان تخبروني من هو برج الحقيقي وفي
ايضا
[موسيقى]
نسبتي 27
امسيه رائعه
58 الى 41
[تصفيق]
على تفويضها فقد املك بلاء حسنا
ثمانيه 68 بالمقابل 30 وهي امراه شابه
وزوجها عام
انسان رائع
وهو لاعب
في اوبو هنورتشرز ايضا في
تفوق كبير هناك عمليه سباق
محمومه استمتعوا بالمساكم واستمتعوا
بالموسيقى وانه نشر كبير ان تكون معنا
وسائل الاعلام اتمنى ان تمتعوا انفسكم
[تصفيق]